euh, c'est sa pensée comme totalement pas
assez bonne pour être productrice de musique, ce qui
est cool et amusant à savoir alors que je suis entré dans le
reste de ma vie,
hé, je vais juste vous arrêter là,
vous êtes la personne la plus talentueuse que je
connaisse et  J'ai rencontré intimement trois des Wiggles
Oh Becca sais-tu à quel point
tu es génial
Becca effing Mitchell d'accord tu es
le grand BM c'est toi tu es génial as
-tu besoin d'un peu de ma confiance parce que je
pourrais peut-être attacher le mien un  notch ouais d'
accord ils m'ont laissé frotter un peu d'accord attends
je pense que tu as besoin d'un peu plus qui vient
de là d'accord merci soigné que je
vais t'avoir les bonnes choses maintenant non je